when when did you get cigarettes the
first time or the millionth no no no
like the I mean the last you have some
time now yeah yeah I have eight years uh
April 2015 wow what happened that was
[__] horrible yeah two weeks prior I
got fired from a I had a sober living
job I was working in a sober house I got
fired for drinking I went on the road
forek and ended up buying Coke and
[__] what I found out was drywall
gypson from a homeless guy outside of a
bar called the gay90s in Minneapolis
it was [__] early yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then what happened that the gay90s
uh I the um I was walking around just
going cocaine cocaine does anyone have
cocaine and it was uh very uh it was
Urban night there and what does that
mean please black and
um the the like one white guy that gave
me Coke was like you got to get out of
here these brothers are un liking you I
was like okay I'm sorry so he sold me
the coke I left I wanted more so I
bought some off a home a guy in the
street and that turned out to be like
drywall dust so I had Coke and drywall
dust and then I got a prostitute and I
couldn't get it up so we just ate trail
mix and I made her put on my glasses we
watch
TV I had the picture of you
you that's so sweet it's so sweet though
that was the last night no that was like
the beginning the no on the flight out I
got drunk at the barn and pissed myself
on the flight and stole a bottle of wine
oh wow and that was like your life every
day then it was the second I put it to
my lips everything goes to [__] which I
used to hate and I would keep drinking
to be like it's not going to be that way
it'll be DIY you'll handle it but God
bless whatever is out there that when I
put it when I put alcohol in my body
everything goes to [__] which now I see
as a blessing because it it my bottoms
happen so fast me too that it it it
there's no chance for me to elongate it
like a lot of people are like if I drank
or did drugs again I might die and I
could die the next day and I'm like no
no no the wor I would wish to die
because the worst thing that could
happen to me would be to drink and
everything be fine and nothing bad
happened so I go oh dude you can handle
it look at that and then it's a Chase to
keep having a night that's okay when
every other night after that is [__]
Mayhem yeah I don't understand how
people people can live with the
spiritual pain of being out there you I
know dudes to this day been out there
for 20 years Comics yeah you know and
and I see them deteriorating before my
eyes and they're they're able to just
hang in there right but for me six
months tops for me you know what I mean
and then i' start feeling it yeah like I
feel depressed I feel like it's all
going to [__] and I can't live with
myself I just right well it's even
tougher when you've been sober for
everybody knows and then you can't drink
around anyone nobody wants to be
involved in that and then you're the
nightmare guy and then you're drinking a
bottle of whiskey behind a dumpster at
8: a.m. you're hiding from your roommate
that is so true I would get messages DMS
about hey we saw Bobby at a bar yeah
like drinking or you would go to the
dispensary and people yeah okay first of
all the dispensary the guy I know what
I'm not gonna blow them out of the water
but I go to this dispensary right and I
buy weed and he's just kind of like are
you sure
man I was had already been out I go yeah
you sell weed here right oh I'm sure oh
yeah right my money's green
yeah and I bought it he he DMS my
girlfriend at the time it was actually a
girl who did it a girl oh my God
whatever it was
from I thought you were going to say bed
bath
and yeah that's the Beyond Department
yeah but um and I I um it's just like
why do they call you and tell you and
ratted me out probably because they're
huge fans of you and worried that you
were spiraling than for caring for me of
course and maybe she didn't know that I
you know I I didn't know at that time
actually that you had relapsed she was
well actually no it was Esther who outed
you Esther outed me [__] [__] oh I'm
going to get that little let's get her
but yeah I don't understand how people
stand it out there I I as soon as I'm
out there for three or four months five
months I'm toast well they stand it cuz
they you keep drinking to make that
feeling go away you know it's like the
worst having sobriety time in your
pocket and knowing that you were sober
and then drinking like the shame and the
self-hatred and everything just grows so
you just have to keep getting drunk and
[__] up to make that go away and then
it's like this cycle that you can't get
out of and thank God you take a sober
breath for a minute you're like oh [__]
and you just just have a little bit of
willingness in a in a in a window to
[__] kick it open and jump through to
the other side you know mhm and whatever
that may be for some people it's like a
deep deep bottom you know for some
people it's you know like losing
everything or this at the other and for
others it's like well I don't like
hangovers but I I don't really judge on
what people's quote unquote bottom is
you know it it's just a matter of
recognizing that like that I I would I
mean there's nothing sadder than not
being able to look yourself in the eye
like in the mirror and be like who the
[__] is that dude yeah this sucks you
know and uh that is is is a terrible
place to be yeah but I also have the
ability to look into the future so I go
this is my behavior now now now let's
see if this continues two years from now
what does my life look like some people
can't do that I can look playing the
tape through yeah I can do it I can go
oh this is going to be bad yeah you know
I mean so it's like I have to stop now